i'd like to introduce you to the radical
concept
that libertarians should vote for an
actual libertarian
we face an election where the only two
people who have a realistic chance to
win
are pretty bad but one of them is a much
greater evil than the other and that
is donald trump effectively we
libertarians have to join one of the two
broad
coalitions and the republicans are the
only one that's
remotely reasonable who should
libertarians vote for in the 2020
election
the presumptive democratic candidate joe
biden libertarian party candidate joe
jorgensen
or donald trump that was the subject of
a three-way online soho forum debate
held on wednesday july 22nd
2020. arguing in favor of biden was
elias sohman
a law professor at george mason
university angela mcardle the chair of
the libertarian party of los angeles
county argued for joe jorgensen
and retired attorney and author francis
menton who blogs at manhattan contrarian
argued that libertarians should help to
re-elect donald trump
here's ilia soman angela mcardle and
francis minton in an online debate
moderated by soho forum director
gene epstein this is a three-way
uh debate you can vote for biden
jorgensen or donald trump
or of course you can vote undecided
which i guess in this case means
none of the above we have a lot to cover
this evening
so i'm going to get right to it i'll be
keeping track of the time
and we'll briefly interrupt each debater
to say when he or she
has five minutes left and one minute
left
we're taking each presidential candidate
in alphabetical order by last name
which means that george mason law
professor elias sohman
goes first in making the case for biden
jane please close the initial vote
ilya you have 12 and a half minutes to
explain why
libertarians should vote for joe biden
take it away ilya so my case here is
pretty simple
we face an election where the only two
people who have a realistic chance to
win uh
are pretty bad but one of them is a much
greater evil than the other
and that is donald trump so my framework
for this is pretty simple
my view on how to vote no actions is
that you should vote for the least bad
candidate
who has a realistic chance to win uh
it's called voting for the lesser evil
and i think there's
a justification for that when there's a
situation where
no non-evil candidate actually has a
realistic chance to win
realistically the chance that any one
vote will make a decisive
a difference in an election is extremely
small
probably only about 1 in 60 million on
average in a presidential election
but if your vote does happen to make a
decisive difference
then there is a potentially big payoff
because that payoff
uh is multiplied over many hundreds of
millions of people in the us
and to some extent around the world uh
and
i'll start off briefly by talking about
joe jorgensen
i don't really have that much quarrel
with her i disagree with her on some
issues but i think she's certainly
better on most issues
than either biden or trump the only
problem i have with her
is that she has no chance of winning
probably no chance whatsoever
indeed it would be surprising if she got
more than one to two percent of the vote
so if anybody can persuade me that she
does have a substantial chance of
winning
i would be happy to vote for her but i
think that's not going to happen
uh the rest of my presentation i'm going
to talk about
biden versus trump because sadly those
are the only two people
who do have a realistic chance of
winning and there are several big issues
where biden has
an enormous edge over trump and all of
them are things where trump has done
horrible things
through executive action alone and ones
where biden
is very likely to either completely
reverse what trump did
or at least substantially tear it back
and the first and biggest of these
is immigration since the coronavirus
pandemic
trump has made the us more close to
immigration
than at any time in our entire 200 year
history
yes shut down virtually all immigration
by people seeking permanent residency in
the u.s
he has also shut down uh most uh
temporary employment visas as well uh
and
his advisors on immigration like stephen
miller promised that they want to make
these uh supposedly temporary changes
actually essentially permanent uh and
there's no reason to doubt that that is
indeed what they want to do
should he win the election even before
the pandemic
trump imposed massive immigration
restrictions uh
reducing legal immigration substantially
trying to close out
almost every potential avenue for it and
in the process he adopted brutal
policies like child separation which
brutally victimized thousands of
children
he has partially now restarted that
policy and we know
uh because he has said so we would like
to restart it uh
more fully in addition trump wants to
get rid of data
which would mean that some 800 000
people who came to the us
as children and have known no other home
whatsoever
that they would be subject to
deportation uh
the supreme court has for a moment
stopped trump's separatists
but they also made clear that he could
find a way to do it
if he just uh crosses his t's and dots
his eyes more effectively
from an administrative law point of view
and it's pretty clear that if he wins
re-election
this is in fact what he is going to do
uh
when you have immigration restrictions
particularly on this scale
it obviously has a massive impact on the
freedom
and happiness and well-being of the
immigrants themselves it literally traps
many hundreds of thousands of people in
brutally oppressive societies
and does so through the use of
government coercion it also has a
massive
economic and other negative impact on
the liberty of natives as well
it obviously keeps large numbers of
americans from
interacting fully with immigrants
through economic relationships and
others in addition it imposes severe
costs
on the liberty of natives for example
we're now seeing
in portland the sorts of brutal tactics
first developed against immigrants
now being used against natives by the
very same agencies that developed them
the cbp ice and others uh
when this is done to immigrants there's
no way to ensure
that it will be not be done to natives
that is what has happened
even before these most recent events
because of the very poor
due process in the immigration system
every year
uh we have a situation where uh
thousands of even american citizens many
of them native born
are detained and in some cases even
deported
by ice the department of homeland
security and other
uh relevant agencies and under trump
this problem has grown worse
uh because he has cut back on the due
process afforded to immigrants
from its already very low levels it's
worth also noting the massive
economic impact of this many thousands
of people are kept from productive jobs
this by itself
is easily enough to outweigh any
benefits created by trump's deregulation
in other areas
this is true if you just take standard
estimates of the
economic contributions of immigrants and
compare it even to the administration's
own
somewhat inflated estimates of the
benefits of its deregulatory measures
uh elsewhere and i would note the
trump's recent shutdown
of nearly all h1b visas
and visas for other highly educated
immigrants is a major blow to american
innovation
uh immigrants massively
disproportionately contribute to
innovation
to the startup of new businesses it's
exactly what we need to get out of our
current economic doldrums
but thanks to trump if his policies
continue uh
that will not happen instead the
recovery would be longer and more
painful than otherwise
would be what can be said for
immigration can also be said for trade
trump has started massive trade wars
with the european union
with canada with china with mexico but a
number of other countries around the
world
when you total up the cumulative impact
of this
it again easily outweighs any benefits
from his deregulation
even trump's own former economic adviser
gary cohn
has estimated that the cost of his trade
wars outweighs the potential benefits of
the tax cuts enacted by the republicans
in 2017
and this problem too is only lightweight
to get worse as the administration has
become more protectionist over time
and trump has replaced uh relatively
more moderate advisers with more
egregiously protectionist ones if
there's one historic libertarian cause
out there
it is surely free trade biden is not
perfect on this
but he would get rid of all or most of
the trade war measures that trump has
instituted
uh and he has historically supported
free trade agreements
uh that would reduce trade barriers
between the u.s
and other nations another issue we're
talking about here
is the issue of government spending even
before the current pandemic
trump and the republicans have managed
to post record peacetime deficits
that have massively exploded and
spending had uh
increased massively under his watch as
well uh trump has repeatedly stated from
the 2016 campaign onwards
that he doesn't care about limiting
deficits from government spending
and that's how he has acted his allies
in capitol hill have also made similar
statements
that is that when there is a republican
in the white house with a few principled
exceptions
most congressional republicans simply
don't care much about
uh restricting spending now it has to be
admitted
by then the democrats are also awful on
spending
and in many cases would like to spend
even more that is currently the case
however we know that when there's a
democrat in the white house
republicans in congress get religion on
spending and do in fact constrain it
as happened under obama and under bill
clinton
uh if biden wins the election uh it is
likely that either there will still be a
republican senate
or that the democrats will have only a
very narrow majority
uh dependent on the votes of more
moderate democrats and those more
moderate democrats together with
republicans
as unprincipled as they often are they
would constrain spending somewhat at
least
to a greater extent than is the case now
let's talk next about projects
uh in remaining five minutes i would
like to go on to the topic of
property rights because i think trump's
horrible record in this area
is underestimated uh trump and his
attorney general at the time
jeff sessions reinstated the federal
asset forfeiture
uh sharing program which essentially
enables
the federal government to help state and
local cops
plunder private property even from
people who have never been accused of
any crime
and certainly never charged or convicted
and this is done
on a massive scale uh in some years
asset forfeitures take more private
property from people
than even conventional burglars do that
is the government steals more property
thanks in large part to this federal
program than even
ordinary common criminals and the obama
administration to its credit had
partially
shut down the federal uh program here uh
but trump fully reinstated it he's
talked about who is it how he's a big
supporter
of asset forfeitures and you can expect
this plundering to continue
probably on an even larger scale should
he win re-election
biden by contrast would reinstate at
least the those invitations that exist
under obama
potentially he might even go further you
can say
tell a similar story about qualified
immunity which is the protection of
law enforcement agencies from lawsuits
when they violate our constitutional
rights
uh even in very egregious cases they get
protection
trump supports qualified immunity he and
the republicans in congress
have prevented the passage of bills that
would get rid of it biden is not perfect
on this but he intends to
support at least cutting this back
significantly whereas trump does not
uh you can uh also with respect to uh
property rights it's worth mentioning
the border wall which is a major
centerpiece of trump's
uh administration if fully built the way
that trump wants it to be
it involves using eminent domain to take
the property of many thousands of people
it would be the biggest federal
government sponsored expropriation of
private property
in many decades if not in the entire
modern history of the united states
uh and it's clear that uh if biden
prevails he would stop the construction
of this thing
i think that's pretty obvious uh you can
also tell similar stories about civil
liberties more generally
look at the secret police tactics that
trump is now
using in portland and wants to expand to
other cities look at the fact that he
has repeatedly urged regulatory agencies
to
crack down on his political opponents
for speaking out against him
uh and there are many similar examples
as well again
biden is not perfect here but uh he's
considerably better than trump and at
the very least
would stop these sorts of tactics that
the trump administration has engaged in
are there a few issues where trump is
better yes he's engaged in some
economic deregulation on a domestic side
but this is easily outweighed by what
he's done
on immigration and trade in some cases
he has appointed good judges but this is
offset by the fact that
his judges tend to be very bad on issues
of abuse of executive power
and on issues of immigration which are
precisely the areas where he would abuse
his power most
if he is re-elected much more can be
said
but for now and on this point uh which
is
that uh if trump is re-elected you can
expect the republican party
to continue to be a nationalist big
government party of the kind it has
become
on the other hand if he is defeated
there's at least the chance that they
will reconsider whether this is the
direction they want to go in
thank you very much thank you ilya
uh next up angela mcardle
chair of the libertarian party of los
angeles
angela you have 12 and a half minutes to
explain why
libertarians should vote for libertarian
party candidate
joe jorgensen take it away angela
hello libertarians liberty means to
exercise human rights
in any manner a person chooses so long
as they don't interfere
with the exercise of the rights of
others and a libertarian
is someone who's committed to living
their life according to libertarian
principles
so what is the purpose of a libertarian
vote
is it about getting libertarian messages
to the masses
is it about voting for the person who
will do the least amount of harm
voting maybe for the most libertarian
leaning candidate who has the best
chance of getting elected
surely the purpose isn't to throw
support behind someone
who sold out your freedoms for years or
even decades
because you're afraid of what the other
guy might do
no i'd like to introduce you to the
radical concept that libertarians
should vote for an actual libertarian
libertarians
should vote for joe jorgensen because a
vote for trump or biden
is not a vote for freedom neither will
push us incrementally in the direction
of freedom
some of us are so caught up right now
defending ourselves in the culture war
that we've lost sight of the fact that
we're being robbed of our liberties
both trump and biden have supported
endless war in the middle east
overseeing the unprecedented expansion
of national debt
militarized police state and eroded our
constitutional rights
a vote that supports four more years of
state-sponsored terrorism
and economic destruction is a wasted
vote that's a wasted vote a vote that
reflects the radical notion that your
money and your property
or your own and that u.s militarism and
inflationary policy should be rejected
is a principled vote now let's look at
some of the issues
that a libertarian president like joe
jorgensen would work to correct
how about economics central economic
planning
is financial enslavement both trump
and biden have contributed to your
financial shackling
and they will continue to do so into the
future
trump's trillions in debt and biden's
five
decades of fiscally irresponsible public
service
have both pushed this country further
down its path of economic ruin
let's talk a little more about trump's
trillions in january 2017
the national debt was around 19 trillion
now it's
almost 26 trillion thanks to the 2.3
trillion dollar
cares act it's the largest spending bill
in history
trump's trillions have ushered in an era
of the very thing he swore to defeat
populist socialism our republican
president
has praised and normalized populist
socialism
and the lack of republican opposition to
this bill
was pathetic and voting for trump will
knock out any republican politicians
inclination to oppose
spending bills like this in the future
just like trump's populism
has decimated the republican liberty
caucus
what happened to in the fed trump
delivered
empty campaign promises just like every
other republican president before him
his first 100 days of office pledge
included a plan to audit the fed
but once trump got comfortable in office
he said the federal reserve should get
our interest rates down to
zero or less when the fed slashed its
rates to near zero in march what did
trump say
it makes me very happy i want to
congratulate the fed
i bet almost every single one of you has
a button
t-shirt or sticker that says in the fed
on it
because that's our libertarian battle
cry libertarians cannot in good
conscience
vote for someone who praises the fed's
mission to print the dollar out of
nothing
in order to finance socialism and prop
up the welfare warfare state
joe biden's tax print and spend policies
will be just as bad as trump's
his commitment to provide free college
and health care will ruin future
generations
there ain't no such thing as a free
lunch trump's bad track record and
obsession with deal making
doesn't rule out the chance that he
might do something similar
because don't forget he tried to pull it
with health care at the beginning of his
term
as death soars our middle class shrinks
and the working class becomes
ever more resentful progressivism and
greed
are fueled by our president's failure to
safeguard our monetary policy
biden will continue this trajectory both
biden and trump have normalized
destruction of the u.s dollar
libertarians need to stand apart from
this
we need to end the fed joe jorgensen has
pledged to end the fed
and support free markets she needs our
vote
and we need to get her message out let's
move next to wars for empire
for years trump tweeted we should
withdraw from the middle east
three months into his presidency he was
launching air strikes on syria
a country that was already so ravaged in
war-torn some of its major cities were
still just piles of rubble
how about afghanistan on september 30th
2019
muhammad saleem and his remaining
relatives had the
miserable opportunity to carry the
bodies of their loved ones
dead men women and children out of their
family home
they were killed in a drone strike
operation the night before a wedding
when air strikes started falling on the
house next door
suicide bombers from that house set off
their own explosives in response
and 40 people including 12 children
were killed in the competing explosions
donald trump is our commander-in-chief
this was done under his watch and every
drone strike murder for the past three
and a half years has been done under his
watch
in january this year trump authorized
the assassination of
iranian general suleimani in iraq
we are not at war with iran i know
it was supposed to be different with
trump but he's continued
if not worsened the same foreign policy
as the obama biden administration
in 2001 don't forget biden voted to
support the war in iraq
and don't forget he's been in the senate
or vice presidency throughout the entire
span of the war on terror
how about yemen for five years u.s
presidents have enabled saudi
governments to starve and
bomb the people of yemen thanks to trump
there are 2.4 million malnourished and
starving children in yemen
how many many children have died due to
trump's sponsorship of saudi arabia's
war on yemen
economic sanctions all kinds of stuff
how much
made in the usa shrapnel has been found
next to bloody corpses of innocent
families
over 100 000 yemenis mostly civilians
have been killed in this crisis
and millions more have been displaced
both trump and biden support a legacy of
militarism that has normalized bombing
weddings
murdering children and committing
assassinations and executions without
trial
they are both directly responsible for
continuing the war on terror
we need a president like joe jorgensen
who will stop
doing this we need a libertarian
president
and if we can't get one we need to push
back
by refusing to vote for the people who
send our troops off
to murder civilians and create blowback
a vote for joe jorgensen is a vote
against the warfare state
a vote for joe jorgensen is of peace
five minutes to go neither trump nor
biden plans to roll back the
surveillance states of course that go
hand in hand with the never-ending war
on terror
they will both renew the patriot act
indefinitely and support policies that
allow and enable the government to spy
on citizens in their homes joe jorgensen
will not support state-sponsored spying
on americans
because joe jorgensen respects you and
she hasn't forgotten our bill of rights
or that we should not be subjected to
unlawful search or seizure
now let's talk about the drug war in
2013
a young entrepreneur sat in front of his
laptop in a san francisco library
working on his website while he was
working he was interrupted by federal
agents and arrested
and subsequently held without bail two
years later
he was sentenced to two life terms plus
40 years with no possibility of parole
and he sits in federal prison today
reading letters from us as often as we
remember
to send them if joe jorgensen was
president
ross ulbricht would not be spending the
rest of his life in federal prison
joe jorgensen would give him a
presidential pardon trump hasn't done it
we know damn well biden won't do it the
war on drugs has failed
biden's 1994 crime bill has ruined more
lives than statistics can keep track of
it's not just the thousands of people
that biden and trump locked up for drug
charges
it's their children and their families
too it's the rape kits that sit untested
on forensic shelves
the murders that go unsolved the cartel
gangs that cross our borders in the
inner city violence of the black market
drug trade
war is hell and so is the drug war
joe jorgensen pledges to decriminalize
all drugs at the federal level
which is the way it should be and what
else waits for us in the wings at the
executive level
presidential powers unchecked biden has
pledged to take executive action
on a number of issues in his biden
sanders unity task force
110 pages that contains lists of
tyrannical things to take executive
action on
including a pledge to expand social
security and fight gentrification
dictators love unrestrained power and
unconstitutional executive orders have
become the norm for presidents
executive authority should be used to
undo unconstitutional actions of former
presidents
like ending the warfare state elected
officials though
will do anything to hold on to their
positions of power including
selling out their supporters by saying
things like take the guns first
due process later and supporting a
federal ban
on bump stocks trump's comments and
actions have emboldened and normalized
gun grabbers and red flag laws across
the country
compromising on freedom never gets us
more freedom in the long run
i want a president like joe jorgensen
who will unequivocally
defend the second amendment i want
people to know i voted for someone who
respects my rights to bear arms and my
civil liberties
and speaking of civil liberties how
about coronavirus and civil liberties
joe biden has absolute contempt for our
civil liberties
he's gone on the record saying he'll use
executive power to force citizens to
wear
masks both biden and trump have
politicized the coronavirus pandemic
but neither of them will do anything to
protect our civil liberties because of
it
the volatile mix of coronavirus politics
government shutdowns
and the culture war has created the
perfect mix
for protests riots hatred and class
warfare
trump has ordered national guard and
federal agents to put down civil unrest
with protests and riots
and while many of us are secretly
pleased to see him own the libs
it sets a terrible precedent for our
future and it drives a wedge deeper
between the left and the right
we need to reject the anger coming from
both sides of the culture war
because it is much more important for us
to own our civil liberties
i don't want a president that says take
the guns first due process
later i want a president that says in
the fed
i want a president that says abolish the
irs
bring the troops home defund the
department of education
i want my vote to count because i only
want to vote for libertarianism
i want a libertarian president like joe
jorgensen so please vote for joe
i'll yield the rest of my time thank you
thank you angela uh
next up uh francis menton
a retired lawyer and author of the blog
manhattan contrarian francis
you have 12 and a half minutes to
explain why libertarians
should vote to re-elect president trump
take it away francis whom should a
libertarian vote for for president
in 2020 and i think the answer is
obvious
it's donald trump the main reason might
might not quite be so obvious it's that
we have a two-party system
each of the two parties represents a
broad coalition of groups and interests
seeking to achieve sufficient votes in
the right places to win a majority of
the electoral college
in the election because we have a
two-party system if you want to
participate meaningfully in a
presidential election
you must join one of the two broad
coalitions
that effectively compete for the
presidency if you refuse to join
either of those two broad coalitions you
are just voluntarily excluding yourself
from any effective participation in the
process and our two broad coalitions are
called the republicans and the democrats
and thus i submit the only real choices
are biden and trump
and between those two with all due
respect to elia
i think the choice of a libertarian for
trump over biden
is extremely compelling i'm certainly
not saying that trump is perfect or even
close to it
but effectively we libertarians
have to join one of the two broad
coalitions and
the republicans are the only
one that's remotely reasonable
i'll spend most of my time discussing
the subject of why we have a two-party
system
and therefore why meaningful
participation in the presidential
election
requires joining one of the two broad
coalitions
when i say we have a two-party system i
suspect that many in the audience we
react with something like there's
nothing inherent and fixed about that as
as uh miss mcardle was just saying we've
got to vote for the person
that we really like look at the uk look
at germany or all
lots of other countries israel italy
australia they all have lots more than
two parties
and those two parties
win seats and they gradually build up
their influence and over time
uh become more important if they have a
good message why shouldn't libertarians
want that why shouldn't they go that way
and the answer is
that our two-party system is a creation
of the presidential election process and
set forth in our constitution the other
countries
the system is different and our
constitution did not intentionally
create the two-party system but if you
look at the history
and the text of the constitution you
quickly realized
that it was inevitable uh the the
relevant text is set forth in the 12th
amendment it's only one
sentence so i'll read that to you here's
the sentence
the person having the greatest number of
electoral votes for president shall be
the president
if such number be a majority of the
whole number of electors appointed
and if no person shall have such a
majority then from the persons having
the highest numbers not exceeding three
on the list
those voted for as president the house
of representatives shall choose
immediately by ballot
the president that's it that's the whole
thing it doesn't say it explicitly but
what this effectively means
is that if you want to elect someone to
the presidency you need to put together
a coalition that effectively competes
for a majority of the electoral votes on
election day
unlike in other countries you can't get
40 on election day and
then do a deal with somebody else who
got 15 to put together your majority if
you're under the majority
you are out and you get nothing the
practical consequences of this dynamic
was not at first obvious but it became
so over time
um the the real crunch
first came in the election of 1824 when
there were four main candidates
all calling themselves democratic
republicans
and uh all four got electoral votes but
nobody got a majority the election went
to the house
who awarded it to john quincy adams as
you know but andrew jackson
who had more popular and electoral votes
in the election
took that occasion to put together
his coalition which became the
democratic party and became our first
modern political party with a coalition
of disparate elements you might not
think their allies
included slave holders yeoman farmers
frontiersmen
people who didn't like cities in the
financial elite it was very disparate
elements who made themselves
into a majority party to win the
presidency
um a couple of other elections after
that in 1832 and 1836 the
the opposition to the democrats couldn't
get together
they had multiple candidates getting
electoral votes and they lost and they
lost again and
the republicans only got it together
when they performed as the anti-slavery
party in the 1850s but they took on
lots of other disparate pieces of a
coalition to put together majorities
that could win the election like
northern businessmen
entrepreneurs industrialist advocates of
hard money and high tariffs and so forth
and that became the uh republican party
and since then
we have had two parties who have very
disparate elements who make
allies to to win a presidential election
which brings me to what for libertarians
has to be the most disastrous election
in american history
that's the election of 1912 and you may
know that taft was the incumbent
president
the prior president theodore roosevelt
also a republican
got into disputes with taft decided he
want to run
at the convention taft got the
nomination
roosevelt said forget about that set up
his own party
and so it was the two of them running
against
wilson between roosevelt and taft they
got 52
of the vote wilson got 41 of the vote
but the republicans split the vote and
wilson got 82 percent of the electoral
vote and he got the victory and
we got what we got the federal reserve
and we got the income tax and we got
world war one
and we got the segregation of the
federal civil service and so forth
wilson's got to be the worst president
ever and it came about because the
the republican coalition could not
keep together to try to put together a
majority of the electoral votes
and i just want to mention one other uh
election with the third party which was
the most successful third party we've
had since ross perot
in 1992 and
uh russ perot put on a real push to try
to get the majority ended up with
almost 20 percent of the popular vote
and zero
electoral votes and the result of that
is
his movement went nowhere after him it
faded away
and uh died and you don't even hear
about it at all
since so today we have two parties that
again represent broad coalitions of
disparate groups the democrat
coalition includes the coastal elites
intellectuals
the media academics government workers
socialists
marxists uh ethnic groups
perceiving themselves as outsiders
people at the low end of the income
distribution
and those on the receiving end of
government spending programs
the most important central theme of the
democratic coalition is the desire to
increase the size and power of the
government
the libertarians should want to have
absolutely nothing to do with that
however the imperfect the republicans
may be
for the republicans the coalition
includes equally disparate groups
uh and five minutes to go yeah five
minutes ago you you might think
uh there's tremendous tension in both
the democratic and republican coalitions
at all time i mean
you might think that that blacks and the
teachers unions
couldn't possibly be in the same
coalition they should be the
most perfect natural enemies but they're
not
uh similarly for republicans and
for libertarians to join the republican
coalition
you you are getting in bed with law and
order people
who are getting in bed with uh people
who are not perfect on free trade but
they're better on free trade than the
democrats
and they're as good or better on
immigration as the democrats which i
will get to in a while
as much as any of us might prefer joe
jorgensen for president over donald
trump the fact is she's not in a
position to make a serious play
for a majority of the electoral votes so
i'll spend the rest of my time talking
about differences between
trump and biden with all due respect to
elia i think he's
he's come up with a list of issues and i
would have to say as to his list of
issues
uh i certainly am am not a fan of trump
on maybe not all but almost all of those
issues but i think
biden is as is as bad or worse and
and biden is totally the creature
of the crazy left wing of the democratic
party that thinks
all human problems can be solved by
bigger government
more spending and suppressing uh all
freedom and opposition forcibly that's
the opposition we're up against and we
have to join one of these two coalitions
so trump supports tax cuts he's put a
big one through biden
actively supports tax increases
including
raising ordinary income tax rates
raising capital gains rates up to the
ordinary rates
and new taxes of all sorts biden
explicitly advocates government
further take over until they control
absolutely all of it of the health care
system
trump has pushed a deregulatory agenda
biden supports more and more regulations
again this should be a big issue for
libertarians
uh the green new deal
biden has a two trillion dollar plan to
increase your price of energy
and and um
drive fossil fuels out of business he's
taking on alexandria ocasio-cortez as
his main advisor on this
he plans massive new spending on pie in
the sky energy schemes with no idea how
they might work
he's promised to eliminate all use of
fossil fuels that's the fossil fuels
that are providing about 80 percent of
our energy and your air conditioning
right now
uh in a july 14 speech you would get rid
of fossil fuels
the energies the electric sector the
economy by 2025 he has no
idea how he could possibly do that
but he plans to impose fast taxes and
growth of government to try
he also is planning trillions of dollars
in new spending to retrofit all
buildings in the u.s
he's vowed to ban fracking which has
which has cut the cost of our gasoline
in half over the past couple of years
and saved the met the american consumer
hundreds of billions
he's backed by people who block every
pipeline and every
energy development of every sort he's
called for the jailing of fossil fuel
executives he's called for a nationwide
ban on plastic bags
and another speech he called for a ban
on the use of all plastic
he's called for an end to shareholder
capitalism
how could a libertarian possibly get on
board with that there's a huge issue of
corruption with biden which i think i
will
save for my next uh piece of remarks
um two things i want to use in my last
couple of minutes
one is justices only one minute
oh well you have one minute and five
seconds one minute and five seconds okay
if you observe the supreme court you
know that the conservative justices have
various
judicial philosophies but the liberal
justice is always voters of block and
most important for a libertarian
the liberal justices always vote as a
block on any issue
that involves growth in the size and
power of the regulatory and
administrative state
they they will support any growth in
size and power of the regulatory and
administrative state
and biden would clearly appoint more of
these people and cement
the leftist control of the court for a
generation and more and the citizens
united case
that's the case where the supreme court
said that corporations and groups can
put together
money to oppose the united voice of the
media
the entire liberal block voted against
it ruth bader ginsburg says it's her
number one priority to reverse
that's the thing that protects your free
speech
and finally there's the ongoing takeover
of the democratic party by the far
far left we've got ten seconds for that
people who run minneapolis and seattle
and san francisco and yes new york they
are biden's people they all support him
they they want one massive federal
bailout after another
rank for three trillion dollars right
now i'm gonna have to
you'll i guess you'll have to finish
that sentence when you do your own five
minute rebuttal
thank you francis madden i appreciate it
uh
and uh we now go uh to uh
rebuttal portion of the evening we're
going to take it in the same order
uh ilia silman you have five minutes
to rebut uh your two colleagues take it
away yulia
so in my rebuttal i just like to touch
on a couple issues
both of the other speakers touched on
the question of taxes and spending
where biden and democrats generally do
have some very bad proposals
but as i mentioned before here the
separation of powers helps us
none of this stuff can be enacted unless
it can get through congress
and as i mentioned earlier uh after next
election either republicans will still
control the senate
in which case it can't be passed on the
other hand it's possible the
democrats will have a narrow majority
but that narrow majority will be
dependent on people like joe manchin
and kirsten sinema and others who have a
very strong interest
in not passing these huge spending and
regulatory
packages if only because it's not in the
interest of powerful interest groups in
their state
for example manchin who is from west
virginia pretty obviously is not going
to vote for the green new deal
and the abolition of fossil fuels on the
other hand
all the bad things that i mentioned
earlier that trump is doing
and the biden will almost certainly
reverse they were done through
unilateral executive action
that fighting could reverse with the
stroke of a pen and will reverse not
because he's necessarily such a great
guy
he isn't but because that's what most of
his party wants
uh and what biden does historically
throughout his career
is he generally does the things that his
party wants uh
unless they would be hugely unpopular
hugely damaging to him
which in the case of these particular
policies uh it would not
i'd like to next talk about the war on
drugs because i think angela
was quite right to bring up the
importance of this and it's something i
wanted to talk about in my initial
presentation and have the time i think
it's absolutely right the libertarian
party is better on this than either of
the others
but it's also true that the democrats
are vastly better than the republicans
uh they're the ones who have almost all
of them support
uh legalizing marijuana nationwide and
also severely cutting back
on criminal punishment for uh other
types of drugs
uh particularly with respect to the
federal rule in there
they also seek to roll back the
militarization of the police
which has made the war on drugs much
more deadly and harmful
uh they recently voted for a bill that
uh
would get rid of a federally sponsored
militarization of police
it's not certain that this can pass
congress uh even if the vine wins but
the chance will be higher
uh moderate democrats are unlikely to
oppose that in a way that they would
oppose
uh some of by these other ideas so at
the very least it's another big
area where uh the democrats are
significantly better
uh lastly on this point about voting in
the two-party system
uh i think it is the case that for
structural reasons
we are at least for the time being stuck
with a two-party system
it will be very difficult or impossible
to overturn
and therefore in the vast majority of
cases
any one vote or even a block of a
thousand votes has almost
no chance of making an impact but
a vote for a candidate that has a real
chance to win
uh there is at least some chance to have
an impact on average one in 60 million
somewhat higher in a swing state lower
in a non-swing state
therefore when it comes to voting what
libertarians should do
is maximize the uh chance of reducing
the amount of
evil uh that might be caused as a result
of the election
uh in other areas where we can engage in
other kinds of political activities
that don't have the same structure of
voting uh there's a lot more that we can
do to persuade people
of libertarian ideas uh to spread them
and therefore to ensure that in the
future the parties have an incentive to
nominate less awful candidates
uh that is currently the case sadly
however the libertarian party
uh has not been very effective about it
it's been around for almost 50 years now
and all that time
it's hard at least at the federal level
it's hard to point to even one
policy success that they have had an
important role in
whereas by working within the major
party system
and also by doing things outside the
party system uh
your libertarians have made a bigger
difference uh i think therefore
uh the activity of voting it should be
separated out from our other political
activities
because voting has this narrowly
constricted structure
where it's highly likely that it won't
make a difference no matter what we do
but in the small chance that it does
make a difference
it can only be if we vote for somebody
who has a real chance to win
whereas other things we do organizing
speaking
contributing money to various groups and
so on there the
structure is different uh and it's
perfectly consistent to vote for the
lesser evil on election day
but promote good uh at other times so
that next time around the next election
the available evils will be less evil
than is currently the case
thank you ilya just uh six seconds under
your limit
uh you did well uh angela mccardle
you have five minutes to rebut your two
colleagues
take it away angela okay let's start by
working our way backwards the
libertarian party has definitely helped
to push the overton window on federal
issues
and one of those would be gay marriage
we were the first party to come out in
support of it
and eventually the other parties did
have to adopt it so that's really great
ilya said before when you vote the
chance that your vote will make a
difference to the outcome of an election
like a presidential election
is extremely small 1 in 60 million
another thing that ilya i anticipated
would talk about but he didn't bring up
was public choice theory
which talks about how voters don't make
much effort to learn about the issues
and survey data
overwhelmingly shows that they don't
know even very basic things about how
the political system works
if that's the case we have to catch
people's attention in order
to actually get them educated and you
don't combat rational ignorance with
radical idea
with uh with rational arguments about
boring two-party candidates
you combat rational ignorance with
radical ideas
no one cares about regular politics and
that is a whole part of the problem
so biden supported record deportations
under the obama administration and he
voted for the 2001 iraq war
there's no reason to trust him on
immigration which is something that will
probably be decided by the legislature
at this point in the fight
his 1994 crime bill he's still bragging
about it
he was bragging about it in 2015 at a
fundraiser
are we supposed to think he's had a
complete philosophical about face on the
war on drugs that he authored
and he does not support legalization of
cannabis and he does not support ending
qualified immunity
he refused to say anything more specific
other than he supports
reigning it in which is a meaningless
statement
his buy america plan furthers trump's
protectionist plan
and commits more taxpayer money to a
plan that will drive us deeper into debt
trump um let's talk about his terrible
appointments
we he he's appointed bolton who's an
advocate for regime
change and military action all over the
world jeff sessions who reversed
holder's reduction of mandatory minimums
and escalated the federal war on drugs
how about mike pompeo the former cia
director don't think that voting for
donald trump will push you in the path
of liberty
it won't another point i'd like to make
is that donald trump is
anti-establishment
but anti-establishment is not always
libertarian the communist party is
anti-establishment
so is identity europa in europe
not everything anti-establishment is
good how about trump's task force
on crime reduction and public safety
he's
increased the funding for the drug war
and the enforcing federal law with
respect to transnational criminal
organizations and preventing
international trafficking
what a mouthful he's also increased
international efforts
and spending on the war on drugs and
cyber crimes
trump's trade wars with china have
damaged american industries like the
steel industry
and cause costs to go up his tariffs
have been terrible for everyone
and social mobility is decreased due to
trump's fiscal policies
there are no promotions on unemployment
none a vote for trump means a decrease
in the republican liberty caucus
presence as well
ron paul's 2008 run had a groundswell of
liberty r's running for office
but not much has happened with them
since trump ran he's basically rendered
the rlc and the freedom caucus
ineffective
and there's no more offensive resistance
to big spending bills
more fiscal issues cutting taxes cutting
taxes without cutting spending
does not result in a real reduction of
our public spending burden
it just changes which pocket gets picked
trump's tax cuts are made up for
with inflation and increases in debt
instead of being paid for by direct
taxes the additional spending is just
paid for by printing currency
which devalues people's savings and by
adding debt
which increases our debt payments and
further limits our ability
to raise federal interest rates on our
debt
trump has increased the federal deficit
as i mentioned previously
as elias stated before your vote only
has a 1 in 60 million
chance of counting so why not vote for
the libertarian
people on both major parties think that
libertarians just want to take over the
two parties we can make them better but
the other two parties don't even want
us voting for a libertarian is a
principled way to vote
the swing state argument and similar
arguments are no different than a
version of don't waste your vote
you're not beholden to vote against
someone evil
by voting for someone else who is evil
it does not change the outcome the two
parties are the same
they are both pushing us in a path of
socialism and economic destruction
thank you angela uh francis mentioned
you have five minutes
to rebut your colleagues take it away
thank you very much
so i come back to the real alternative
for libertarians is to join
one of the two big coalitions and then
what
and then work within that coalition to
make
it move in a libertarian direction and
that in fact
has been happening substantially the
republican party was basic
basically establishment go along get
along
when i was younger today it has a big
freedom movement
in it you may say that it has that
freedom movement
has diminished in the last few years but
over the past
20 and 10 years it's greatly grown and
it's our responsibility to grow it some
more
rather than going off on our on our
own uh little movement which will have
no influence on
uh anything um
on the one in sixty million that ilia
has that's like the total number of
votes i want to point out as
as most people here know the 2000
election was won by 500 and some votes
in florida do you think that's the only
such election believe it or not because
i studied elections for
purposes of preparing for this the 1884
election was won by
approximately 1 000 votes in the state
of new york
by grover cleveland if if new york had
gone the other way
the election would have gone the other
way and similarly the 1960 election was
won by
some very small number of votes in uh
illinois by
richard nixon um
here is a question that i think we
really should address what if i live in
a non-competitive state like new york or
california
uh why don't i vote for the libertarian
candidate
because trump's not going to win that
state anyway and will show that the
libertarians have some support
out there and i i will admit that i
followed that theory and voted for gary
johnson in the last election
but here's the risk last time trump lost
the popular vote
if he doesn't waste his time campaigning
in states he's going to lose anyway he
risks losing the popular vote again
which will increase the outrage and the
um claims of illegitimacy
against him even if he wins the election
again in a way similar to what he did
last time so i think it's important
for republicans to come together as
close as possible
in the blue states in order to prevent
this from happening
the more trump votes trumps get the
harder will be to accuse him of being
illegitimate
and it will help his ability to advance
elements of his agenda favored by
libertarians like deregulation supreme
court justices tax cuts and the like
now i want to address at least a couple
of the points raised
by ilia let me try immigration because
i'm
i'm a fan of more rather than less
immigration in general
but immigration is a complicated subject
there are about eight billion people in
the world and probably half of them
would like to come to the united states
if they get the chance
unfortunately that's not practical and
it could swamp our constitutional system
very easily
uh existing law permits about a million
people a year to come
that's a pretty good number i think i
mean you might argue for more
and you might argue for less but a
million people a year is a pretty good
number
um now trump up until just recently with
the virus hasn't really cut down on that
recently he has but i think it's going
to go back to the million because that's
basically what congress
has said maybe we think it should be a
million and a half
but it can't be 50 million or or our
country would just be immediately
swamped and once that whatever the
number is
if even if it's a million and a half or
two million it still has to be enforced
and you can call the people
storm troopers or children in cages or
whatever
every time somebody gets arrested in
this country they get separated from
their family
i'm sorry if they're if they're here
illegally
they're going to be arrested and removed
and there really is no
alternative to that okay i want to
address the biden sanders unity task
force angela
angela mentioned it this thing
is a hundred and ten pages of every
progressive
wish list every spending program the
takeover of the energy economy the
takeover of
education by the federal government the
takeover of the medical sector of the
economy the takeover of the housing
sector of the economy
every big government idea on every
subject from the green new deal
you name it stephanie kelton is one of
the members she's the modern monetary
theory
woman who says just print money and
spend infinitely that's the theory that
the democrats now have and that biden
explicitly says he backs and one final
thing biden corruption which i said i
would get back to
uh in my opening if you look at fine is
one corruption after another and ukraine
i'm sorry you're gonna have to have to
get to that in your q a
uh in the q a section so uh i just have
to enforce the time you know i mean this
is a thankless job here
and i've kind of whipping people into
shape uh guys
thank you very much for your initial
statement and for your rebuttals
we now move to the q and a portion
of the evening and the first thing for
me to do
is to go around and in the same order
and first ask ilya do you want to put a
question to
angela to uh francis menton
or to both or do you want to wave the
honor for the time being
you can you can take the prerogative
asking a question later
you want to check that prerogative now
elias selman
uh i guess i'll ask a question to
francis now which is that
uh in your presentation you talked about
the history of the two-party system
but it seems to me that the separation
of powers here is also important
and i wonder do you have an answer for
the fact that all of the harmful things
that trump has done
uh that i've listed are in fact one that
he's done through unilateral exercise of
executive power
and therefore it can be expected to
continue whereas nearly all the bad
things that biden might do that you and
others have mentioned
they do depend on getting through the
legislature and does are much less
likely to happen
uh francis benton please answer the
question if you can
okay i i i can't think of how you could
say that the guy who invented the pen
and the phone was
obama as far as i know and he had a
series
of uh pretty incredible uh executive
orders
and you could call it bad but one of my
favorites is
daca because daca
obama ex completely admitted that it was
not
permitted by the law and that he
couldn't do it he said multiple times
that he would love to do it but he
couldn't do it
and then he just went ahead and did it
in defiance of the law
um
another example that's totally from the
regulatory state the green power plan
which completely
would um shut down
uh all coal power plants to begin with
and all other power plants
of fossil fuel after that that was
totally done
uh by regulation and with no
uh legislation behind it and biden
totally announces that he intends to
transform the entire
energy economy based on what he claims
is a view of environmental law
and already in place and he's just gonna
do it and cost the american people
trillions of dollars by doing that so
i i just don't agree with you i'm not
saying trump is great but biden is as
bad
and worse worse worse i guess i may i
just
uh moderated prerogative to intervene
you were referring mainly ilya to uh to
biden's tax plan which
which some of us believe is kind of a
war on capital
uh and that would have to be approved by
the house and senate so i guess
is that what you were mainly referring
to no not just that i was also referring
to
his most of his regulatory initiatives
uh
various spending programs and so forth
all of that would have to be passed
by congress and for reasons that i
mentioned earlier
it's not likely to be passed even if the
democrats get a narrow majority in the
senate
because people like sinaiva and manchin
and others are unlikely to
vote for it uh buddy uh francis
mentioned do you have a response to that
or do you want to wave the honor
well i'll just say one sentence which is
i think the whole green new deal thing
large large pieces of it they're
planning to do by regulation which means
by executive action
not not asking for new laws from
congress
uh angela mcardle do you want to comment
on the exchange between ilya and francis
take it away angela if you'd like to
comment on what they just said to each
other
well i agree i agree that a lot of the
110 page
unity task force proposals are going to
be achieved through executive order
because that's what it says
it says it right there however donald
trump's spending which we have all
witnessed in the past three and a half
years
is not much better and it looks like he
has basically just adopted progressive
spending and slapped a maga hat on
it and an elephant and called it owning
the libs or
voting to protect our freedoms which are
all honestly
just that fight is being it's happening
at the level of governors
so i don't see a major difference
between the economic
policies between the two of them they're
just wearing different scary masks
it's the same disgusting body uh
angela uh do you want to take the
prerogative to ask a question of either
ilya
or francis or both at this point you
want to wave the honor until later
sure i'll ask francis where do you see
the republican party in about 10 years
well uh angela i am an optimist
and as i have advocated in my
presentations here i think we
libertarians
should become active in the republican
party we should work with the republican
party and we should
work to move it in our direction and to
make it a party
of smaller government it pays lip
service to that but in order to actually
accomplish it it needs
libertarians libertarian-oriented
republicans in the congress it needs a
libertarian-oriented president
and and for the reasons i've stated
that's only going to
come via libertarians working through
the republican party to accomplish it
i'd like to see that happen
uh do you want to comment angela on on
francis benton's response sure how about
what we've seen with the rlc and the
freedom caucus basically being destroyed
under trump's
populist agenda it doesn't look like
joining the republican party is actually
working out right now
it uh it doesn't seem to have much
liberty messaging
well i i think it does have liberty
messaging and again i said in my
presentation
that the uh freedom caucus of the
republicans may have diminished
some over the past few years but it's
increased a lot
over the past 20 and 10 years and and i
would hope to regain that momentum
ilya do you want to comment on the
exchange between uh
francis said earlier that the liberty
movement is growing in a republican
party
it's seen immediately he must be
observing a very different republican
party
than the one i've seen over the last
several years in reality
what has happened to republican parties
and embrace a big spending
an embrace of severe restrictions on
civil liberties trade wars
uh immigration family separation and so
forth all the things i mentioned earlier
even an embrace of things like asset
forfeitures beyond what uh
occurred before building big border
walls by confiscating thousands of
people's property
uh and so on and if you look at the
intellectual trends within the party
it's not even just trump sort of the hot
younger people in a republican party hot
poetically not necessarily physically
are people like josh holly and tom
cotton
both of whom support big government
nationalism so
if we want a republican party that moves
in a different direction
uh it has to be a republican party that
gets beaten
from moving into the trumpet direction
that will give it some incentive to look
at other things
uh those possibilities may still not be
great from a libertarian point of view
but they're likely to be at least
somewhat better than what exists now so
uh if you look at what republicans are
saying
people like holly people like trump
people like cotton and others in the
party
they're they openly talk about how they
reject limited government they reject
free markets
they prefer protectionism and
nationalism uh
and it's unlikely that we can move them
off of that
unless they get a political incentive to
behave differently
okay uh francis mention your turn
would you like to put a question to
angela to uh ilya
or to both uh take it or you'd like to
wave the honorarium later take it away
francis
maybe if you're working in that comment
you couldn't get in francis go ahead
i'll just ask elia to comment on the
biden
uh sanders unity program for a federal
takeover of everything
how could you support biden with that
i have two answers one is it's not a
takeover of everything though it would
be a takeover
too many things uh but my other comment
on that
is what i said before that most of it
would have to pass through
congress even the parts that they say
they can do through regulatory action
a lot of it would be undermined in the
judiciary
there's a lot of republican judges out
there who would not be happy to
approve those programs uh finally in the
in that community program there actually
is some stuff that is actually
good like reducing militarization of the
police
cutting back on uh things like acid
forfeitures and qualified immunity
and also some pretty good measures on
immigration and all of those things
actually abide and could do uh through
executive action
uh at least uh given that most of those
there are things where trump has so far
gotten away with
uh unilateral executive action it was
interesting to me earlier when you
were asked when you tried to name things
that the democrats did through executive
action
one of your only two examples was daca
which is actually a really good thing
protecting 800 000
innocent children from deportation i
don't agree by the way that obama said
it was illegal you can argue
uh about whether it was illegal or not
but to the extent that it survived
it's actually a good thing for a
libertarian point to do a very obviously
good thing actually
angela would you like to comment on the
exchange that just took place between
your two colleagues
i don't think so thank you okay she will
not condescend to even comment on what
you guys
just said to each other uh and so uh now
i want to use a
moderator's prerogative to ask you each
question i'll take it in the usual
alphabetical order uh
ilya you're probably aware of of course
the things that uh your true colleagues
have alluded to
and let me uh meaning uh that the
democratic party is
now making greater peace with
the bernie sanders wing of the party and
that uh
if i may add to the ghoulish statements
that are being made about biden
we're going to have a brain dead
president who's going to report to nancy
pelosi
or maybe attack it from another
standpoint
could there be a vice presidential
candidate that that biden appoints we
don't know that yet
so maybe a little bit premature in this
debate could there be a vice
presidential candidate that he appoints
that would so horrify you that uh you
would uh
vote libertarian to vote for trump all
of those fears about how
a biden presidency is going to be
passive and indeed that
whoever he appoints his vice president
could take over
will probably that he'll be a one-term
president and we could have
some kind of sanders uh uh era
ahead of us what is your responsive
attitude
my response is twofold one is most of
the people he's considering
they don't look that much different from
biden himself in terms of policy
preferences
with the possible exception of elizabeth
warren who at this point at least it
seems
unlikely that she will be chosen
moreover to the extent that you think
biden will be relatively passive
that reduces the chance of harmful
executive action on his part
on the other hand even if he's generally
passive he will at least reverse
all the things i mentioned earlier that
trump did even if
he himself may not be super motivated to
do so his party really hates those
things and from the standpoint of his
party
reversing all those things is relatively
low-hanging fruit because it can be done
through executive action
whereas most of really bad stuff that
the party wants to do
mostly on taxing spending and certain
kinds of regulation
that does have to get through congress
and it will be very difficult for it to
do so
uh even if the democrats do get a narrow
maturity in the senate
it is true there is a very harmful wing
in the democratic party to bernie
sanders wing
that's a bad thing i'm not happy about
that but in the democratic party or i'm
saying the republican party
the harmful dangerous swing the big
government nationalists
have already taken over the party
they're already in the white house
already in power stephen miller trump
himself
holly and others sad between a party
which has a bad wing
but that has not taken over at least so
far and a party where the bad guys the
worst guys really because they're all
bad guys
these are the worst guys they have
actually taken over i prefer the one
that hasn't been completely taken over
by its worst elements
to the one that has uh angela would you
like to comment
on ilya's uh answer to that question
i don't believe that the democratic
party
is going to fight hard against the
progressive element
i believe that the progressive element
is dragging the rest of the party
along the ride it's that's the way that
it's going
and so when we talk about oh it's just a
it's an unsavory element i don't and i
don't like
it it is the future of the democratic
party and i think that that's something
people need to consider
do you want to vote for that and help
that to
gain traction in the next not just four
years but 20 years 50 years
the time that you're alive in the united
states is that what you want to support
francis would you like to comment on
ilya's answer to
that question i i thought angela
gave an excellent answer the
the progressive wing the socialists and
the marxists
are rapidly taking over the democratic
party
and controlling its agenda
even though they might be a small part
of its voting base
and i don't see that changing i see it
only getting worse
i think the audience appreciates
yesterday thank you very much let me say
one more thing which is
libertarians have no place in the
democratic party the chance that
libertarians could go into the
democratic party
and move any of it in our direction is
zero
that's it i think the audience
appreciates as to why
the ways in which alliances swing in
this three-way debate
uh i mean francis uh it's uh
now you're don't know i'm sorry it's
angela's turn to sit nazi
with my moderator's question it's a
similar question really
to the one i put to elia that uh that
joe jorgensen is
a faux libertarian uh angela as you know
she made a statement uh about how
libertarians must be
very active with the anti-racist
movement that they must
sort of uh implied that she should uh
that we should all be in solidarity with
black lives matter
and that was a statement that many
thought was not the statement that the
libertarians should make
and that therefore she's truly not a
representative
of libertarianism and how would you
respond to that
absolutely it's a very legitimate
concern
she did not make the tweet herself
someone on her staff did and it was
course corrected a little bit right
after joe is trying very hard to reach
out to people who are not libertarians
but i got to tell you that joe is an
excellent candidate
she is 10 times more principled and
articulate and
economically literate than gary johnson
and she knows where aleppo is
and she's definitely not a marxist we
hold joe to a much higher standard
than we hold the other two major parties
because she's our candidate
and we care about her messaging and
something that i found to be really nice
is that joe and her campaign manager are
actually responsive to feedback
and i guarantee you that donald trump
and joe biden are not responsive to your
feedback
uh yoja would you like to comment on uh
on the uh answer to that question uh or
you want to wave the honor
sure why not uh so i think anti-racism
is one of these terms it has many
different meanings
in the most extreme left wing meaning of
it obviously it's something that
libertarians would not support
but in the ordinary language meaning of
it it just means being opposed to racism
and in particular being opposed to a
government which discriminates on the
basis of race
uh and that's in sharp contrast by the
way to many of the policies that
uh donald trump and the gop have favored
including large-scale use of racial
profiling and immigration enforcement
where even under obama but now even more
so under trump
official policy is that you can use
racial profiling
which means racial discrimination and
immigration enforcement
so long as it's within 100 miles of a
so-called border area
which turns out to be areas where
two-thirds of americans with
uh so i i think you can argue about the
term
anti-racist but i think in the way that
joe jorgensen probably meant it
i think she was right and that
libertarian should be anti-racist in the
sense
that we should oppose claims that one
race is inferior to another
and that the government should be able
to discriminate on the basis of race
uh and ethnicity and similar
characteristics
and when it comes to things like
immigration enforcement law enforcement
generally
uh while the democratic party is very
far from ideal
they are better than a republican party
in this area i do recognize the
democratic party does have flaws in this
area on the affirmative action front
but as between discrimination when it
comes to things like college admissions
uh and discrimination when it comes to
matters of life and death
when immigration law enforcement the
party which does it when it comes to
matters in life and death is worse
uh francis would you like to comment on
ilya's comment or angela's comment or on
the question
regarding joe jorgensen yeah i that was
specific to angela and i'll wave coming
okay all right your turn to be in the
hot seat with the moderator buddy uh
francis
uh and uh the question is
a similar one to the one i put to ilya
and angela
which is that uh trump is a kind of a
full libertarian a pro
pro republican i should say and uh
indeed also a former libertarian you you
mentioned the free trade that free trade
is was a plank in the republican party
but
you seem to concede that uh trump is uh
clearly not a free trader
uh for example and uh and then uh
the point that elia made was that
a repudiation of trump's presidency
uh if it goes down to defeat could
result in the possibility that the
republican party could repudiate
trumpism and go back to its roots
and so can you comment on that broadside
attack against trump
well starting with
um if biden wins
or if trump wins there's going to be a
different republican candidate in 2024
and the republican party can move away
from trumpism equally
at that time whichever one of the
candidates went
on on the question of free trade yes i
am basically a free trader and trump is
not
uh i guess that's a question of how
heavily you want to weigh that
i don't think that trump has greatly
undone free trade
um there he made a big deal about canada
and mexico
after a while we have a new deal i i
would say i prefer
the previous one i don't know all the
details but
uh i think it's a number of tweaks but
it's pretty similar
in the case of china yes he's made uh
some huge changes to previous free trade
but i would say china
it is a bona fide security threat and
there are big security issues and he's
absolutely right
to be dealing with that and even though
i'm a free trader i think the security
issues with regard to china
have to be dealt with by whoever is
president now
the final thing basically between the
republican party and the democratic
party the republican party has
much more the free trade party and the
democratic party is much
less the free trade party with their
uh particularly with their labor and
environmental
allies so as bad as trump is
i think we are better off with trump and
the republicans than biden and the
democrats on free trade issues
elia do you want to comment on another
question on francis's response
yeah just very briefly uh first it seems
very unlikely the republicans in 2024
will suddenly repudiate trumpism
if in fact it seems politically
successful which it would seem that way
if he were to win re-election despite
the horrible current economic crisis
and the coronavirus pandemic and so on
uh
secondly on the issue of free trade i
think it's pretty obvious that the
republican party has become much more
protectionist
than the democrats that's a change
compared to 10 or 20 years ago but it's
a real
change i just give the example that
trump withdrew the us from ttp
a major free trade agreement that would
have encompassed numerous countries in
the pacific and by the way would have
helped to counter china
that agreement was signed by the
democrats they would have passed it
uh trump uh withdrew us from it in
addition he has started trade wars with
almost all of our allies
with the european union uh with japan to
some extent
canada with mexico even by the way after
the new
version of nafta he still has kept in
place various various tariffs on
canada and mexico that he put in
supposedly as webridge for those
negotiations
uh so i think there can be no serious
doubt that the republicans are far more
protectionists than democrats right now
even though the democrats certainly have
plenty of flaws of their own
and if trump were to win the election uh
that would confirm the republican party
as the
strongly protectionist party that it has
become angela do you want to comment on
the question
uh and none or your colleagues answers
to that question
no i guess just a short comment that
neither party is good on trade and
and i think that actually the other two
two professionals have explained that
pretty well i think
i think we all have a pretty good idea
of where everyone stands joe jorgensen
is very free trade open to trade the
other two are not
thank you uh we have a question that
came in from the audience uh
here's one for ilia the question writes
trump has not started any new wars
and it is safe to say jorgensen would
not either
how can we trust biden to show the same
restraint uh shouldn't that be a deal
breaker
for libertarians can you answer that
question julia
i think we are more at risk of new wars
with trump than with any of the other
alternatives
because trump is engaged in repeated
dangerous saber rattling
with iran and north korea and even in
some other contexts
and also trump is deeply ignorant about
the state of the world
so he could easily end up in a war
addressed to his own stupidity or
miscalculation
and at the same time trump through his
trade wars
and other policies has deeply alienated
most of our allies
and therefore if we were to get into a
conflict we would be more likely to not
have any support from the allies
i think biden's judgment isn't perfect
on this but
he did show considerable restraint when
he was in the obama administration
uh and it seems unlikely that he would
start a war just through
stupidity or miscalculation and if he
were to enter one
we would have he would at least be with
significant allied support and therefore
the burden
uh would be more reasonably shared uh
whereas
under trump any awarded he would get
into would be one where he would be
isolated
do you want to come in on that uh
francis by way of the honor
uh i'll wave the honor
angela you want to wave the honor or do
you want to comment i'll do a short
comment
i've taken a good look at biden's voting
record and he's been definitely more
dovish in the past 15 years than he was
in 2001 when he voted for war
i certainly don't trust him on this
issue though because he did vote for us
to go to war with iraq
and the democratic party has been up in
arms about everything with russia trying
to just scream you know we need a cold
war with russia everything is so
ev everything you know is hysterics with
them so no i don't trust that biden's
foreign policy
would not push us into war at some point
i
i i'm glad it's biden not hillary that's
the most
that's the nicest thing that i could say
about the dnc right now
right uh thank you angela
and uh here is a question for buddy that
i guess picks up
on a slight disagreement or maybe a
major disagreement that you and elia
just had
uh why would the gop move away from
trump as
ideas that got them elected why would
they move away from trumpist ideas
that got them elected or indeed as helio
was saying if trump
is triumphant in this coming election
why wouldn't they just embrace those
ideas
in the next election but the simple
answer is we have to bring
in voters who who agree
more with our ideas than the so-called
trumpest ideas within the republican
coalition in order to move the
republicans in our direction
and that's the reason i don't i don't
think what
what is being called the trumpest ideas
i don't think they're going to go away
we have big alliances of disparate
uh interest groups in both of the
political parties
and so the republican party both the
republicans and democrats include
protectionists and and also
some free traders the republicans have
more free traders
and we need to make it even more in
order to move it in that direction and
not
every libertarian that goes off in their
own direction and has their own
political thing independent from the
republicans
is is one more person who's not trying
to move the republicans in that
direction
uh do you want to comment on that elia
right just briefly
if the republicans can get libertarian
votes in their current state
to the extent that they even think they
need libertarian votes which it seems
like most of them think that they don't
uh but she extended they think that they
do there's no incentive for them to
change
to the extent that libertarians can
affect things by voting
it's by in any given election voting for
whichever party
uh of those that has a chance to win is
the one that is least bad for their
point of view
if on an issue like free trade you end
up voting for a party there's actually
more protectionist
than that more protectionist party has
even more incentive to discount
whatever we might think uh regarding the
free trade issue i think that's
uh pretty clear uh do you want to come
in angela
oh yes no libertarian messaging will be
drowned out under trump's populism
if libertarians rush right now to join
the gop
all we're going to do is be labeled
republicans
gop people every insult under the sun
that is attributed to donald trump it's
not the right time
to try to to try to charge the cockpit
on that that was ron paul's run
and that's not coming back if we get ron
paul 2.0
fantastic and i'll def i'll revisit that
debate with you but i'm telling you that
that is the only situation where i would
give any respect to the notion
of trying to rally behind republicans
it's not going to work out for us right
now
okay well uh that concludes the q a
portion
and uh we're now going to go to the
summations and in the same
order uh we're giving you each seven and
a half minutes to summarize
you can take less than that if you'd
like max at seven and a half
uh ilia uh tell us once again
why we live a chance should vote for joe
biden
so i think i laid out the main issues in
my initial presentation
there has been very little attempt to
even begin to refute most of those
so i'll just remind people of the points
about immigration
trade property rights civil liberties
government spending that i mentioned
earlier all of these are huge
issues all of those are issues where it
is very likely
90 or more that things will be better uh
if
biden wins that if trump wins uh they
might be better still if joe jorgensen
were to become president
uh but she probably pretty obviously is
not going to happen
i would like to briefly comment on the
immigration issues some of the points
that francis made
uh in that it is not true that trump
failed to cut immigration even before
the coronavirus pandemic
to the country he had reduced refugee
admissions for example from some 100 000
a year
to almost nothing and that happened even
before
the pandemic began he also cut many
categories of legal immigration
and of course ramped up deportations
family separations
and other kinds of brutal measures you
can say well that happens
with any kind of crime that there's some
kind of family separation
however uh when people are convicted of
a normal crime they at least get normal
due process
there is no such due process with family
separation under trump's policy moreover
uh the only crime here physical crime at
all is the
crime of crossing the border which in
the criminal code is a minor misdemeanor
there's no other misdemeanor to my
knowledge where people are routinely
uh separated from their families in such
a brutal way
usually for most misdemeanors you get a
small fine or community service
uh or the like so the brutality of this
policy is enormous
and it's a departure from previous
policies even though previous policies
uh were very bad and i mentioned earlier
how this is a threat
uh to the liberty of natives citizens
and not just to
uh that of immigrants this issue of well
the entire world could come into the us
uh i think this like many things where
people are allowed to live
should be determined by free markets and
individual choice
as libertarians that is what we should
be committed to entered the bogeyman
of everybody would come in that seems
very unlikely
it didn't happen in the first 150 years
of american history
when we had mostly entirely free
migration from the world
and limitations of housing and
employment markets uh
could also not constrain that but even
if you don't support me in wanting a
presumption
of free migration there's still room for
much more
uh freedom of migration that exists
under trump where
right now there's virtually none uh and
he and his advisors have made it clear
that they want to extend that
indefinitely
even miller is his main advisor on
immigration issues
and miller has made it very clear uh
that that's what he wants to do
uh the issue of the war on drugs is also
i think significant
earlier uh why the democrats are
generally better on this than the
uh republicans with the issue of war
again i think the
issue here is the trump because of his
ignorance and velocity
is more of a risk than biden though i
don't claim that biden is risk-free
i also think uh and this is a broader
debate to be had perhaps in another time
that i don't fully agree with those
libertarians to say well we should have
a neo-isolationist policy where we never
use military action unless we are first
attacked they think there are other
situations where it could be justified
and leaving the field to the world's
authoritarian powers
like russia and china and others doesn't
strike me as the best way to go
even i also don't think that we should
have you know just
massive wars any time we think something
is a problem
uh and i think biden can strike at least
some reasonable balance on that and that
is in fact where his positions
have been over the last 10 or 15 years
uh though i certainly don't expect he
will be
anywhere near perfect on that finally
on the two-party system and what
libertarian shooter promoter ideas
uh i think the act of voting is
separable for most for
other activities because it has this
characteristic
where uh only two parties have a real
chance of winning
and any one vote has so little chance of
making a difference
that therefore it makes sense to cast a
vote
uh for the party of the two that have
the
a real chance of winning that is the
less bad uh and in most cases it won't
make a difference but in a small chance
that it does make a difference
that's the only way to have any kind of
payoff on the other hand there are many
other things that we can do promote
libertarian ideas
make contributions to organizations
engage in issue-specific
activism do scholarship and research in
writing and speaking
those can uh popularize libertarian
ideas through society
and make them more accepted and
therefore change over time
the incentives of the major political
parties
where libertarians have succeeded in
doing these things however
it has generally not been by working
through a third party
it has either been by working in the
major parties or outside the
party system all together that's how
milton friedman
hayek iran the drug legalization
movement
the school choice movement and many
other libertarian causes
have had a measure of success uh over
the years
and we should talk more about how to do
those things but when we're talking
about
the narrow issue of who to vote for in a
particular election
i think sadly uh there is not a better
alternative
uh than voting for lesser evil and in
this particular case
the western evil despite his flaws is
indeed joe biden
uh it's certainly not donald trump thank
you
okay under seven and a half minutes but
um uh
angela you have seven enough minutes to
uh summarize
the case for joe jorgensen take it away
angela
i wanna see liberty achieved in our
lifetime and i admire
everyone who is fighting for freedom in
whatever way they can
there are some libertarians who are
trying to force political change through
the two major parties
and there are some who have folded to
their own cynicism and discouraged
others from any political action
altogether but there is a third choice
it's using the libertarian party and its
presidential candidate
to educate people and win hearts and
minds
the only way to achieve libertarian
values
is to promote libertarian values we will
never promote libertarianism
by promoting the values of biden or
trump especially in today's political
climate
we use our presidential candidate to
spread the values of liberty
offer voters a principled third choice
and force the other two parties to pay
attention to libertarian issues
why not make voting meaningful by giving
it to joe
and working to get five percent of the
popular vote you'll guarantee ballot
access for several states for the
libertarian party
make headlines and get liberty all over
the news
this is also a vote where principal
non-voting libertarians can be assured
that their vote
will not result in an act of aggression
against
to others the only way to beat marxism
is with liberty
not with national socialism or populism
and joe is an
excellent candidate you don't protest
against a candidate who's libertarian
by throwing your vote behind the biggest
collectivist monsters
of modern human civilization it's
understandable we hold joe to a much
higher standard than we hold the other
two
candidates because we care about her
messaging because she's supposed to be
our beacon of liberty
but the reality is that no human being
or candidate is perfect in everyone's
eyes
ron paul is the paragon of liberty there
are still some people who don't like him
because he was personally pro-life
would you rather support someone who is
wildly unprincipled
in order to cast a spite vote or would
you rather support someone who is
highly principled that you disagree with
on one or two minor points
right now hope isn't connected to a
landslide with
win at the polls it's connected to
pushing the overton window
in the direction of freedom and we need
your support
to send hope out to the masses
collectivism
under the banner of the left-right
paradigm is one of the strongest poisons
americans have ever drunk both parties
are
toxic collectivist tools that are
pushing this country
down a path to socialism one claims to
be
slightly less socialist than the other
the other claims to be more socialist
but nicer reject them
never forget the reign of death that was
brought on by hitler stalin and mao
would never have happened if people
hadn't discarded their love of liberty
and abandoned individual rights for the
sake of tribalism
civilization has never been advanced by
a collectivist dictatorship
and both trump and biden suppress
innovation with regulatory capture
or economic destabilization or the
threat of nationalization
both of them and their parties have
pitted friends and families against each
other
now hatred boils over and politics has
bled into a culture war
but as libertarians we shouldn't be so
easily fooled
to take up arms in the wrong fight
during the past 40 years
for example federal gun rights have been
eroded under republican administrations
federal spending and debt have soared
the dollar
is basically just an empty promise and
donald trump
is directly responsible for the
escalation of these things during the
past three and a half years
democrats like biden have brought us
disastrous socialized medicine
and they're ready to try it again the
democratic party has dragged biden to
the far left
and they're trying to drag the rest of
us there with them or destroy us along
the way
by distracting us with racial tension
and class warfare
throughout the past 12 years
libertarians
and the ron paul remnant has screamed in
frustration
where is the anti-war left well i
screamed back
where are the anti-war libertarians
where are the in the fed rallies
where are the tax revolts have we
accepted unending war and socialism
and just given up all hope is it
acceptable to use our votes
to re-elect a war maker who destroys the
dollars and our civil liberties
i say no it's time to shift our paradigm
and let go of all this two-party baggage
so we can fully embrace
freedom don't give in to this evil just
proceed
ever more boldly against it don't
believe the lies of the trump versus
biden fight
economic freedom and personal liberty
are not divisible
and neither trump nor biden cares about
the damage our foreign policy is doing
overseas
what if our foreign policy of the past
12 years hasn't served our national
security interests
or our interests at home when will we
stop learning to meddle in the affairs
of others
when will we stop punishing people
overseas when will we stop
torture enhanced interrogation spying
spending
regime change when will we finally stop
inflating and borrowing
what if we stop being gaslit by 40 chess
propaganda
and the argument that we should vote for
the lesser of two evils
what if we just stopped voting for
evil what if we finally just embrace
liberty
and let go of our obsession with trying
to wrestle power back
from the jaws of a totalitarian
republican monster
that doesn't care about us this is your
call to action
it's time to redirect political dialogue
with principled radicalism
radical freedom takes all forms it can
wear a suit and tie have a normal
haircut
it can put a libertarian sticker on its
minivan where a vote for joe
button radicalism can attend to protest
or dodge its taxes
no one is interested or excited when you
tell them you're voting for biden or
trump
no one is intrigued when you tell them
you're too apathetic to vote or that the
system is
rigged everyone already knows
people are interested when you tell them
that you're voting for the candidate who
wants to abolish the irs
and bring the troops home people pay
attention
when you tell them you support a
candidate who wants to restore our
second amendment rights
and end unconstitutional spying and
torture of american citizens
it's not about voting for trump there is
no go big or go
home we need to go big and vote
libertarian
because this is our home we need to
recapture the narrative
of what it means to be free and
reinvigorate
our party our message and our principles
let's bring back in the fed rallies
let's bring back the anti-war movement
and that's why i'm asking you to vote
for joe jorgensen in 2020
thank you angela uh francis menton
you have your seven and a half minutes
to make
your final case for donald trump take it
away francis
i i just want to start with dealing with
a couple of the points that elia made
that i ran out of time to
uh to address in my in my prior
presentations
uh on immigration
um elia finally made it clear in his
closing that he's really in favor of
pretty much free immigration and you
know if you're an economist
and you look at immigration you quickly
realize that
the thing that can increase welfare in
the world the most
the single transaction is to bring
immigrants into the united states they
raise their incomes tremendously they
raise our incomes tremendously
it seems so attractive but the idea that
we can have
completely free and open immigration is
just ridiculous we would have four
billion people trying to come here
we couldn't possibly deal with it and
so then the question is how many
are you going to have you have to draw a
line somewhere is it going to be a
million a year a million and a half or
half a million
and once you have a line then then the
line has to be enforced because if it's
not enforced there is no lie
and and you can't say they treat these
people harshly they have to be arrested
and deported
that's what it means to have a line i'm
i'm sorry i don't like it i know lots of
immigrants
i know lots of illegal immigrants living
in new york city
or at least ones i pretty sure are
illegal and they're extremely nice
people and hard-working people but
unfortunately there is really no
alternative
to it and you can get a little more or a
little less but that's why i
basically don't count that as any
particular
major negative on trump we're going to
have about the same amount of
immigration
either way i think it would be more with
biden but it would be illegal
they would be much more open to illegal
immigrants biden and his people
but that's not okay that's not what
congress has said
uh the war on drugs
neither party is any good on the war on
drugs i would like to see the war on
drugs
done away with
i think the democrats are just as bad
and in fact biden is the guy who
supported the 1994 or approximately 94
act that increased all the penalties
and and trump is the guy who supported a
reduction of that that doesn't mean that
trump is anywhere near perfect on this
he certainly
supports uh vigorous enforcement of the
drug laws but if anything he's better
than biden
okay those are just a couple of
particular points that i wanted to
address
um i come back to my main point is which
is you have to pick between the two
major parties and a commenter at my
blog put it very well a couple of days
ago
what what the commenter said was
voting for trump is like forcing
yourself to eat your broccoli
particularly if you don't like like
broccoli it's very
distasteful but voting for biden
is like eating a gigantic dog turd
and i think that's very well put
so um there is there is absolutely a
worst-case scenario here
which uh uh miss mcardle and i think
she's done a very nice job here but
that she hasn't dealt with she she wants
to see the libertarian party get five
percent of the vote
well with the libertarian party getting
five percent of the vote
that could very well put us right into a
modified repeat of the 1912
election where one or two
or three swing states get thrown from
trump to biden by a division of the vote
and now we get biden when we could have
had trump because we
we voted for purity it's it's
unfortunately the perfect is the enemy
of the good just like the democrats are
all
are all now uh trying to compete over
who can be more pure and canceling the
ones that aren't
the republicans and the libertarians
can't afford to play that game it's a
loser's game
as much as i think that wilson was the
worst president in us history biden
could well be worse
i think you're just kidding yourself if
you think that biden is any kind of a
moderate
and i think that's completely that
concept is completely disproved by the
biden sanders unity platform that came
out a few days ago and that we've
discussed a few times in this debate if
you have any doubt about it you ought to
read that 110 page document which is
joined by every
crazy left winger and big government
person in the country this is the
government takeover of everything
fast new spending fast new taxes vast
new regulations
fast new energy costs it's also the
ascendancy of the woke
the people who think that believing in
freedom is hate speech and racism and
white supremacy
that's but that's biden's people it
means supreme court justices
who will approve suppressing the speech
of anyone who does not agree
with trump as president there's at least
some possibility of pushing back against
the purges from social media from
academia
and and from from the media of all
dissenting voices
such as yours they want to purge you
with biden as president and the woken
control the move to silence libertarian
voices
will accelerate so trump may not be our
favorite but he's our only option for
pushing back against the very
very malign forces with whit for which
biden is the current figurehead and the
front man we need to vote for trump in
fact more than that we need to try to
get him as big as victory as possible
hopefully a landslide so that he'll have
people in congress
and he can get some libertarian-oriented
things
accomplished indeed if we really care
about libertarianism
it's our duty thank you okay well that
was uh
under your lighted time thank you
francis
uh we uh i want to thank all three of
you
i learned a lot i think our audience
learned a lot from each of you
jane or would you please take over and
supervise the voting
and now i want to uh
i want to uh announce the uh
the winner uh first of all uh
i do want to say guys that uh
setting aside the oxford style though uh
in the final vote joe jorgensen got
sixty point three percent
now that's not the expert style vote but
i only want to tell you guys that
joe jorgensen would be winning the
presidential election
with 16.3 of the popular vote
had it only been taken among the 200
listeners we had this evening
so i want that firmly understood uh
francis and ilya and angela you can
certainly crow
on that basis and then i guess i also
want to add
that joe jorgensen also won uh the
oxford style vote
uh she went from 27.8 percent of the
vote
to 60.3 she picked up
32.5 uh now
uh coming in second was
trump who picked up three percent
uh biden lost a couple of points uh
and so he came in third but
uh it was a fairly close race between
biden
and trump but i do want to repeat that
angela
gets the tootsie roll uh and ilya
you uh i loved your presentation francis
i loved yours
uh but you came in third francis
you came in second i now want to ask you
if you're all on
on on on the tube uh uh francis
who do you think will probably win the
presidential election will you
uh that we're gonna have to have an
election among 60 million voters
not among the 200 this evening who do
you think will probably win
francis the election the election is
among 100 million and more but
sorry yes i i think trump's going to win
uh who do you think is going to win i
think it's most likely to be biden
uh that's a conventional wisdom but the
conventional wisdom on such things zinc
is right most of the time
and angela who do you think is gonna win
i have no idea until i can find out
um how many more riots we're gonna have
until then
coronavirus i think right now it's
barely
trump in the lead but if he if he
fumbles a ball before then i think that
he could slip we'll just we'll see how
many more people he
throws a knapsack over on the west coast
okay you guys still apparently disagree
about everything
including the future uh so again
thank you all you all three of you have
been great this has been a real pleasure
and good night to everyone out there we
will be back in august